Shhh- shut the fuck up...
Crash Bandicoot!
[imitating] It's just like Dark Souls!
You guys just can't stop, can you?
Ca-aa... Everything is just (uh) Dark Souls.
[imitating] Oh, the game is a little difficult!
[imitating the disabled] It is just like Dark Souls!
This Monster energy drink...
Aaah, it's...
JUST LIKE DARK SOULS!
[crybaby] Ooh, the game is a little hard...
[crybaby] Uuuh, buuuh, uuuuh.
But let me tell you what.
This game is  e a s y.
Zero deaths, baby.
Number one... Let's Player on YouTube -- that's...
... that's me.
I've never died a single time in any video game ever
I'm here to prove to you how easy this game is
You crybabing? son of a bitches
Here we go
[imitating] oh the game is a little hard, it must be like Dark Souls
it must be like Dark souls
Oh My God, it's got boxes.
Just like DARK SOULS
*Brutally Mutilates Boxes*
Wow!
*More Boxes Die*
We Got inventory...?
Aw shit, this is actually pretty nostalgic
I don't know about you guys. I never played the first Crash
Uuh I played the...
...the second and the third
And I played them with my mom, she would always...
*Struggles to find words about what his mom did to him*
Uuh...She would always just get a bunch of lives for me, so I could beat the bosses
Ha Ha
T-haha
I mean this is just like Dark souls!
Wow it's so hard... it-it's really difficult honestly
Wow it's so hard. It's really difficult. Uh, honestly.
I-I-I must be incredibly lucky to not have died yet. It really feels truly incredible.
It really feels truly, incredible.
Oh shit get FUCKED turtles
*Turtle bullying intensifies*
*Conga music plays*
*It sounds fabulous*
*Sound of Pewds killing innocent turtles*
Oh look at that. Is that the end of the level!?
Zero fucking deaths baby
EASY!
BOOM!
YEAH!!
EASY!!!
Perfect, baby! Did he just vomit that out? Okay.
Perfect baby!
Did you just vomit that out? Okay
*Sound of death itself plays*
ZERO deaths baby.
Fuck the boxes. Okay? Fuck 'em
Oh look at that, just like Dark Souls. Perfect. Thank you.
Oh look at that another zero deaths.
Oh, it's almost like this game isn't hard at all.
This is so weird
Okay, so it's a boss fight coming up
Maybe I spoke too soon, because the dar- cause' dark souls is famous for having brutally difficult
boss fight uh-fights, whatever
God, what is he possibly going to do?
That was pretty much impossible to dodge.
I guess I have to learn his movesets or something
Wow......
This is pretty much impossible
Again, no, like WOW incredible
I get it now
BOOM!
ZE-RO deaths, baby
Hell yeah, man.
Oh my God, you guys this is EXACTLY like that one part in Dark Souls
This is exactly like.... Disney, Fantasia
*Sound of Pewds snorting something*
To be fair this is pretty difficult, like you need lightning reflexes.
You need to be practically on drugs to play this
*Like the ones you were just snorting?*
Dying is for pussies and dead people, and I'm not one of them...all right
What the fuck is that shit? What the fuck is that?
Fucking cancerous piece of shit game, what the fuck when do I jump?
Jump... what the fuck is wrong with this fucking thing!?
Jump... WHAT THE FUCK IS WRONG with it?!
When do I jump why do I need a pig here anyway?
The fuck is this fucking shit? it's so easy to tell on those
what the fuck
What is this fucking shit??!!
What the fuck?
What the hell?
Okay, how about I don't jump then, cuz I know everyone's like "you have to not jump on that one"
Is the game glitched? like I can't get over it. I can't get over it. Look how easy those are why is this one impossible?
It makes no fucking sense. It makes no fucking sense
What the fuck?
*getting angry* Okay, sure sure
Okay, sure sure
Sure let's uh, Let's all the sudden throw in an impossible jump in the game. Yeah that does that make sense. That's cool
Let me get over this fucking thing
What is that? I don't get it
The jump is impossible
Is there like a boost button? I don't get it.
OOOOOOOOOH!
YES!
*gets rekd*
Fuck you!
It is possible. It is possible to do the jump
(Moans)
What the hell it was super easy. Can you FUCK OFF?
(Moans more)
(Speaks Swedish) But that was in holy fucking hell, fucking shit.
(something on swedish, idk google doesn't translate)
This is not fun any more. I like legit just wants to move on.
Please
(Speaks Swedish) Like what the fuuuck
You can jump over a fucking dentist board with a boar in Dark souls
Thank you. Thank you. Fuck off. eat a dick. Hope you die of testicular can-
Jesus christ.
Can someone turn on the fan? It's so fucking hot.
I have zero deaths. That level does not fucking count, okay!
It does not, count this game is easy, please, stop
Just stop
stop
Let me-
Stop!
(mockingly) It's just like Dark Souls
(Gibberish)
(still mocking)OH MY GOD! this game is duck like a duck though
okay, now we're back to the regular platforming which is the easiest of the easy by the..
Fuck
What the fuck is he anyway like a raccoon?
Squirrel frog, what is he? It's like just oh what you want with all free life. Thank you kind sir. Thank you
Squirrel, frog, what is, what is he?
It's just oh, what you want oh free life? Thank you kind sir. Thank you, kind sir
bitch
Wow, that was really that was a tough one. Oh
Oh wow, that was really, that was a tough one.
Not the flowers
Not the flowers, okay, give me my fucking mind back, piece of shit game
I swear, give me my fucking mines back
Piece of shit game
ZER-O-DEATHS baby if you don't Have 0 deaths in all games ever then don't even talk to me
Alright, don't even bother
speaking
Just go
fuck
When does this game get hard again?
just curious
Let me know if you know
Whatever, okay?
The game gives you extra things if you fuck up, just like Dark souls
Fuck.. WHAT FUCK WERE YOU DOING?!
(Moans yet another time)
Whatever. It doesn't count if I die, okay it doesn't count
How else do you think I get zero deaths come on
(some weird accent) Not today bitch, not today, No. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye
easy
Does this level fucking ever end?
Jesus Christ
My God, thank you
WHOO!
(even weirder accent) Easy, Easy game
Hey look at that. Look at that. A new area does it get hard now?
Does it get hard now? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
that's what she say
(cackles)
Yes, bitch.
Yes
Fucking speed run this shit
Kids never played 3D platformers before, is that the problem? (Italian accent) but I play
(Italian accent) Super Mario, okay
That's why I have a these accent
Y'all nibba never play Crash?
Shame
Shameful
(weird accent again) But I swear I play Dark Souls
I Got to the first boss and then I fucked up man
This little raccoon game too hard. Too hard for me man
Fuck I'm de-AH
That doesn't count alright. Stop ;-;
Zero deaths all right?
(weird accent again) Oh, man. I- I love playing Sims 4. It's just like dark souls
I love decorating the house.
Not today monkey son of a bitch. That's right. Give me my checkpoint. BITCH
I'm an.. the fucking fish almost killed me. I'd say almost because I can't die
bish
Bish, what?
what'd I just do?
Well, what's the point of that. Will these come back? uuh I see hidden path over there
What the fuck where am I?
y'all better go back to playing candy crush, all right?
If you think this game is hard
you clearly never played uh...
Fuck you
goddammit
Hey, mate. Fuck you fucking piece of shit flower
Plants, I never liked them anyway, okay? No one likes a plant.
If you're a plant fucking unsubscribe from this video
I mean, I'm not kidding you
(feminist voice) HE'S DISCRIMINATING ALL PLANTS NOW!
(normal voice) Yeah, that's right
What you gonna- Fuck you
You think I'm gonna miss the box, think again
you flower loving shit
(random person's voice) You've changed man
(normal voice) all right
Boom and now I fuck my bitch. Why does he keep stealing her? I don't get it. She's ugly
That's right. I said it. Just like dark souls. Oh, it's another boss okay. Oh, well this should be difficult
Fuck. What the fuck. How do I know where he's gonna jump?
What the fuck is that shit?
what a fucking piece of fucking shit. This boss sucks ass
Why is it..
What kind of raccoon can't even swim
(random person's voice) He's a fox Felix how could you not tell
'Cuz it doesn't have a fucking tail? I don't know
Bitch, you're getting fucked now what you gonna do? whatchu gonna do son. Oh, no? Ow, what the fuck I got fucked
Get fucked, get fucked get- He dodge-
(Speaks Swedish) But it was your-you fucking bastard.
You're going to fucking die, YOU'RE GOING TO FUCKING DIE!!
YOU SHALL DIE!!
(Scarce's voice) Hey guys Scarce here. We're going to play a boss that it's completely fucking random and uh,
it takes no skill at all you just got to get lucky and that's a pretty good game. It's almost just like dark souls
also I- I quit youtube
(Ripper Roo's immaginatary voice) oh, oh, oh no I don't like it
Bitch
That's right. I jump on you. I jump on you on purpose
(Speaks Swedish) Well that was the fucking cunt's fucking cunt.
Just.
Fucking.
Die.
Please.
Great, great, just great. Just great. Just fucking great. Just great. This game is great. I'm having a great time
This is just what I want this is what I need, huh playing this game with this fucking piece of shit broken ass game.
What the fuck is that shit?
Oh, but uh, you see the reason why  the crash- the new crash is harder because I suck at games now.
Oh, oh, shit, uh
You gettin completely destroyed, man
(Speaks Swedish) Noo. Well that was fucking shit.
Get out of my spaces!
Fucking shi- Ripper. Poo.
okay, alright, alright rough start rough start and
If you're tuning in right now, uh basically having died a single time yet, I'm an mlg player
Pro, I don't know if that's even a thing anymore
Basically I can't die. I'm untouchable I've been battling this boss for the last 20 minutes
And it's not because I've been dying it's because I.. It's just an epic battle that never seems to end for some reason
But I have not died yet
And as you can see here. It's going great everything is going -
what did I say??  ZERO DEATHS
ZERO DEATHS
men det va da fan hahahhah
why did I say you know I don't even feel like celebrating cuz I was..
Haha, so eAsy
My God that was easy. That was Ah-Sah
ah, ow
Ooh, so easy, you know I actually realize now
Dark souls and crash Bandicoot are the same
Because they're both so easy
Leave a like for if you think crash bandicoot is a raccoon leave a like if you think he's a fox
Leave a like if you think he's a video game character
my name is peewdiEPIE
and..
stay awesome sisters
Easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy
easy easy easy easy easy easy
easy
aza
az
azy
aze
saza ma name is
SAAZA